so much that you've already said you've
you've written this book incredibly
popular book a higher loyalty and so
many people have read it and you've
talked about it so much I I kind of
wanted to get into some areas that might
be fresh and new starting with what's
happening today and what maybe you can
give us your perspective on it okay
President Trump tweeted this
I'm gonna guess at 4:00 in the morning
no idea he's referring it he's referring
to James clapper the former Director of
National Intelligence and he says and we
can put it up clapper has now admitted
that there was spying in my campaign
large dollars were paid to the spy far
beyond normal starting to look like one
of the biggest political scandals in US
history Spygate a terrible thing
exclamation point what the hell is he
talking about what what is it what is
this you are the former FBI director of
what is that it's best I can tell it's
made up yeah I don't know where he's
getting that from honestly and a number
of things he's announced with the
biggest scandal since Watergate my guess
is two weeks from now there'll be
something different than this but I
don't know anything about those facts
right so and do you find that to be at
all possible or probable and I just play
devil's advocate that there was a spy
inserted into his campaign by an
intelligence agency I don't find it
possible and I know it not to be true
okay all right and the facts are
knowable and I gathered today there was
a meeting on Capitol Hill where
Democrats and Republicans got to see the
actual facts which is why I'm confident
that something else will be bigger than
Watergate next week really yeah what no
he'll find some he'll fight about it
yeah oh but this well that's I think
they're with me for a second we were all
if you're like me my heart stopped and I
thought you're about to break this
incredible Annie and then you told us
something we already know which is that
Trump's gonna make something up right
he'll get an undercooked burger that's
bigger than water so okay this raises an
interesting question which is a lot of
people have said and I want to get your
perspective on it that Trump is engaging
in this kind of chaos this game of
kicking up dust chaos creating chaos and
sort of creating mayhem to distract
from actual facts do you think that he
is intentionally doing that because you
know the man you've spent time with the
man or is this something he just does
because he's always done in his entire
life I don't know I I so I don't know
exactly what his thinking is I know that
the attacks on the institutions of
Justice are just bad whether you're
Republican or Democrat and so whatever
the motivation is it's something that
the president United States shouldn't do
mm-hmm because it undermines the rule of
law we should find out what the facts
are and now we have a special prosecutor
who's looking at the facts I don't know
what he'll find I just know if he's
allowed to do his job he'll find the
facts here's what's interesting you have
independent investigation is crucial to
running this democracy you know a
powerful independent law-enforcement
agency
the problem is once that agency as is
the case with the Russian investigation
starts to look into a political process
an election it immediately becomes
politicized in the way that the
investigation into Russia suddenly I
mean Trump could have said right after
he was elected I was elected I think I
would have been elected even without
this intervention by the Russians but
I'm determined to get to the bottom of
it and I think everyone would have
approved of that
yeah and that frankly I was shocked when
that wasn't his reaction that should be
the reaction of the President of the
United States but it always happens that
politicians worry about the future and
so try to undermine and and sort of
hedge their bets against whatever the
outcome might be I get that but to try
and accomplish that by attacking the
institutions that we all need is a
mistake we should all regret
you